what do I know about heels oh I know
they shouldn't be on me blister my feet
are already red Oh can I get some
assistance please nothing that
good-looking
I don't know what I'm getting myself
into from what I understand the high
heels are very uncomfortable when worn
over a long period of time I'm done I
start saying notice why your calves look
great you want your ass to be lift it up
your feet are gonna hurt a little bit I
can't I woke up this morning and I stood
in front of my closet for like ten
minutes like what goes with heels do
they really have to be this sparkly I
think it's gonna be awesome I think I'm
gonna feel tall which is I mean the
silent hope of every man as long as I do
better than Ryan I don't care this is
the [ __ ] max how am I supposed to walk
in there
[Music]
[Music]
the heels and we're like drill my feet
are sweating are your feet sweating oh
yeah it's not the only thing my heels
are sinking into the is my life right
now we're midway through the day right
now I don't feel great my feet are
really sore my thoughts on heels are
very much the same as they were in the
beginning that they're stupid we're
walking to lunch now while some of us
are walking some of us are waddling let
me be literally limping oh wait this is
uphill and I don't like it at all thank
you to keep it together all this I'm
stepping in for real
Oh put that back in your shoe that is a
sweat the whole side what hurts the most
y'all the balls and balls in my feet
hurt my pride my pride probably hurts
the most of all my god-mom aunties
cousin sisters that I don't have women
in general women in general I applaud
you so I leave you know honestly I've
never got heels I've never understood
why girls wear them I think they look
just as good without them
[Music]
no I don't think wearing heels makes a
girl more attractive
I think being comfortable makes you
attract what I will say when you take
that [ __ ] off
it's like a damn orgasm
[Music]